what's up everybody
uh we are back for another
live stream today we are going to be
finishing up
our shopping list looking at
generators classes
iterators and uh maybe
even a little puzzle that that's one of
my
favorite little puzzles to do so all
right thanks for joining us today
if you are new i am sam i
am from python basics and beau
and quincy are hey jan how are you
um allowing me this wonderful
opportunity to
share my joy and love for python
so all right like i said i think we're
on our
uh eight
i don't know jan wait this eighth or
ninth
jan helps me stay on task he's a
he's a champ for me all right so let's
let's one
get into what i i completely forgot
so we need to start looking at this so
this is how you solve the problem
if you have a file that has spaces
and you're calling from dos it's a
double quote i
forgot and i was using a single quote
code camp dot py close that out
and boom you get you get your file
so let's look at a couple of problems
right here
so we've solved
we've solved a lot and i want to add
this i can't remember if i talked about
tell or not what tell does
it is this it is very handy so if you
lose track of where you are
and oh and forgive me for the coughing
uh
i've been trying to treat my throat uh
ben actually didn't talk most of
yesterday my kids made fun of me
they started whispering but uh no i'm
gonna try to hang in there as much as i
can i think we can get through
everything and i have a pile of cough
drops in front of me uh
dude did some tea and some uh honey
and even tried uh letting dark chocolate
melt sorry if i cough a lot i greatly
apologize but all right
tell it actually tells you where you are
in the stream of the file so
we're gonna i have this here and if you
get
if you're getting an error especially
then input output
can't read or write
yes it tells you the position where you
are in the file stream
so that's actually kind of where i
theorize where the term stream
came from it's a stream of data so when
i have an open file
it's uh in the documentation it called
it
it called this
uh did it open
this is where you are return a stream
so there we go so what tell does is it
tells you the position
so if you're at the top of the file
you're zero and then
um like if we're gonna run this
let's get into it let's just stay right
here
and then i have it as an easter egg as
please tell
please tell so
i'm at 71. so one thing that
we need to go over is what is happening
right down here so we
are we grabbing our
list our our file
we're turning it into a list that we
enumerate
let's bring this back up here uh
shoot i got okay you guys should be able
to see that
yeah perfect so then
i'm wrapping this in an enumerator then
i'm turning it into a list so that i can
count it
then i'm unpacking it then printing it
to the screen
now what happens is once i choose
which one to delete if i pick a non-zero
then i go back to my
list sorry something just fell behind
the computer
hang on one second
sorry guys i thought something was back
there probably something's about to fall
hopefully it's nothing plugged in here
all right sorry about that guys would be
about right
okay so then i go back to my list
and and i have to
i'm going to then delete something out
of the list
and i'm enumerating so that's why i'm
subtracting one so
i know because we have to adjust
from the user to the file the user is
not going to tolerate
this this being zero
through whatever number they're going to
want to see one
through however many so that's why we're
adjusting
this to minus one then we're literally
just taking that list
and rewriting it to the file so that's
why we go w here
so we don't have to go and get fancy
we're just gonna
literally reopen the file
with w completely recreate it right over
it
and write our new list now i want to
show you
this right here
the user will not want to
they're going to sit there and if
they're in this part of their
list they're going to want to maybe
delete
more than one thing at a time so we need
to figure out
how to get that list to come back up so
we're already here writing
so what did i tell you guys how
you can do both at the same time
anybody remember
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to add a
plus sign so we can do write
and read so when we write
we are at the end
so basically it's going to be because as
we're writing down
we're putting in we're inputting we're
at the end of the string a
we're at the end of the file so we just
wrote we went to the file
now we've changed this so we can read it
as well
so now we need to do is come here
and after this let me make sure this is
going to be in the right spot
yep so now we need to go
file file dot
seek because we're jumping
we want to jump to the top and then
literally
it's just this all again
so it's items equals list
all right so since it's the exact same
i'm going to copy it i know i know i
know it's probably going to
break but i don't want you guys to be
have to be tolerant of so all right what
did i do there i did not do tabs i did
control
close bracket and how i need new to do
control close bracket is indent
indent region control close bracket
so then i save this again then i exit
then i run
so then i list okay then i want to
delete
shoes
so then i want to delete jelly so boom i
get the list
back every single time after
i write it and then
i come back up here and i'm back to the
top
so there all right so that wraps
that up so 0 to continue
and then exit all right
so now onward onward to new things we
have wrapped that up
so i hope everybody has had a good week
um but yeah i just always want to
appreciate uh bo
and quincy for affording me
this awesome opportunity but yeah uh if
you're new here
um i've been studying python
for about seven seven years and teaching
for about five and have had my youtube
channel
for three and a half oh my goodness
almost
almost exactly three and a half years so
any of these videos
actually all of this content has already
been done
once before in micro videos and i'm not
smart enough to come up with that name
micro video
one of my subscribers did so all right
let's comment this
out and if you're new here
no but i you look down
thank you i got you all right so
if you are completely new highlighter
region
alt shift comments out everything
and then alt s saves here's
actually here's one thing if you are
super super new
awesome glad you're here but here is a
fantastic way to know
if you have not let me see how bright
big that is if you do not know if you
have saved the file
so it's going to have this asterisk up
here and also
you run f5 and it's gonna jump because
this is gonna tell you
hey you did something even if you even
if i
even if i do one return it's gonna jump
up here and it's gonna ask me to save
again
so there we go all right classes and
generators
all right we're going to go super slow
because this can get
out of hand really really really quickly
all everything in python is an object
a type of variable a variable
is a class and
so
all right x is an object
it's a variable that 5 is assigned to x
and that type of variable is an int
all right that's our starting point
that's how we're going to move forward
okay now
let me see sorry i don't know what's
happened
i'm falling apart i'm 43 and
everything's
everything either hurts something always
hurts or something sore like
nothing's always working all the time so
all right
we're gonna build we're gonna create an
object that's a rectangle
and um and also let's look at list
because this is this is a great one so
so we have der on y
so this is this is what we're going to
be doing
has anybody ever heard the term double
underscore
you won't ever hear me say dunder have
you ever heard of dunder
i'm not just asking i will never use
dunder
but this is double underscore and let's
see
in it there's iter so we're going to get
into iter
we're going to get into uh
len we're gonna get into uh repper
and now there we go and where's string
okay these are the things that are
happening in the background
and here are methods that we can use
these
happen and python uses
all right i'll say that again this is
what
we use these are what python uses
so we're going to create an object we're
going to create our own class
rectangle and we're just going to go
from there
okay and of course we're going to use
the keyword class
and we need to look at
in it do i have this position right all
right
so in it i thought it was literally
in it this is in it the first time i saw
it
but it's initiate and it uses new
so as you can see where did we go let's
close it let's string that down
uh new boom
all right
there's in it okay so new and in it
all go together but what this does
is how do we create what do we do to
create
how does this object come into existence
so we're going to set the rules of how
this object comes into existence
so literally you're creating a brand
think about it as you're creating a
integer or we already know how to use
integers
and lists and tuples but now we're gonna
you're creating a
new something new that you're gonna need
to use
that is gonna react on its own you're
creating a new object like a list
you have a list things can come into it
can come out of it and you can do things
to the list so here
and when you're creating an object a
class
just these are methods right
and i said that they act like functions
we know how to create a function
so it's the same structure you just
utilize them with the dot notation
method
so the very first thing you have to do
is initiate it now this next word
can get really weird really really fast
self
the best way that i have found to
explain this is
like this
that y is a list
but it is its own self right
so this is each time
you're going to create an object it is
this type but it is itself
all right does that make sense to
everybody
you'd only if you need to jan if you
need to
um if it's super complicated
possibly but you wouldn't want to get
into any import air probably
you'd already want that in the file that
you'd want to be using
like a pie game file you already have
that in
with your loop you wouldn't want to
have any issues with bringing it in
unless it is ace
even a overly complicated or an
excessive
object it wouldn't be so big that you
wouldn't be able to fit it in the file
and i would uh this is reference
re shuffle
you only want to have your own files
because then when you get to having
uh then we're talking about packages uh
not only would you have modules but then
uh
then packages i mean you could but
oh actually that might be a good lesson
for us to get into
um the double underscore main
maybe we can do that next time oh uh one
important admin note
i haven't gotten to tell bo and uh
quincy yet
uh we're not gonna have a live stream
next week
uh i've got i've gotten a little behind
a little bit so i need to take a
a week off i'm not gonna even have any
videos on my channel
so we need to do that you you can't you
can
jan but i i don't recommend it unless it
is a
super super complicated item and then we
can go from there
so all right a rectangle basically we
have
uh the rules of a rectangle
two sides two sides so
length length
width all right so
same rules same rules apply
now here's where this gets
weird so since
this
this is its own self in this
instance so you have to think of these
as their own instance
so we do self dot length
equals length
all right so you're bringing this in
you're taking in input
you're then going to assign this
to this i know it feels so weird right
now
but am i spelling everything right yeah
okay so then
self.width
equals width okay now we're going to do
something
let's see any questions no not yet all
right
so let's put this into memory
what do we call this
didn't mean to do that sorry guys
so much to talk about about our shopping
list still but
who who said it was making them hungry
the shopping list
yeah i was glad i was able to get up and
uh but uh
oh tech what's up tech okay
so all right we have our
our new x we just dumped memory
aha so it knows to
have it's going to when you need to pass
in our length
and our width so we're just going to go
three
by three okay
so then i call oops so then i call my
object
so right now we've
created it we've initiated it but we've
done absolutely nothing
with it now this is where
this is where the programming and the
fun starts
let's just add a little bit here and
because i'm going to show you the wrong
way and i'm going to show you the better
way just
just to show that we've done something
sorry um
oops i really would have bet any amount
of money that i
that i muted that
all right any questions so far
you're
is links
by
width and then
close that out save this
boom so i now have something go out to
the screen
that the that our
programming user goes okay i know
something happened you put something out
to the screen
awesome thank you for doing that
okay well we have a we have a rectangle
we usually want to know stuff about it
right
so now we are going to look at a way
so that python uses this now
why don't we make a method that
we can use all right
not a big speller as i'm sure you guys
have noticed
so this is going to be short for
perimeter if i start typing perimeter
it's not going to go good all right
let's see so
again i'm using myself so we're using
this
we're regarding the object that we just
created
are our x which is a rectangle
all right and let's see where we are
uh oh okay so perimeter
it is our length times width
times two so
so let's do that two times
self
width times
self length
all right let's run this
boom so now
now i want to challenge you guys with
something that is a method
what attributes do we know right now
about x
anybody got any thoughts and it's fine
if you don't
because this was one of the things that
threw me off for a very very long time
about a natural difference between an
attribute and the method and
things like this
so the attributes that i have right now
are length and width and it's just
information that is associated
and this is where my self comes into
place
the self length and self width
take in from here and assign it
back to itself that's why this comes up
i guess i should have done 3 and 4 so we
can see to make sure that we did
did this right and now my perimeter
so 3 times 3 times
2 is 18. so i did the math correctly
here so now let's do
what's the other one area why don't we
look at area
def area
self then print
uh so what that's just uh
side by side self width
times self length
one glue good there we go i'm sorry if
sorry about the cough drop hopefully
it's not driving anybody nuts
okay put this back in memory
hopefully that's not too loud either
sorry uh
yeah let's change this up a little bit
make sure should we show that we're
doing all right
your rectangle is three by four so then
we call
perimeter 24
let's check that make sure nothing
changed right 4 times 2 24
okay so now x dot
area 12.
so the area is 12
square whatever centimeters square feet
uh don't know i guess we did not uh
maybe that's something else and then our
x
uh let's check this length
boom width boom perfect
so everything's going
pretty good right now so now
now let's get into
a little bit more stuff so right now i
have my double underscore
in it and that's that's a cleaner nicer
way to say double underscore and the
reason why it's called double underscore
let's look really really close if i can
get you the right
one there it is so
one two one two
never found in the pep why it was two
um but that's why it's double
double underscore because you literally
are depressing
and putting in place two underscores
all right so now in our init
we have this we're getting something out
of the screen to share to the
programming user
that you have created something and
this is it right here but
that's not best practice
i'm going to show you
what the best practice is
something that's called
wrapper the official rep string
representation of an object
and guess what it has a
double underscore method and then we're
going to go into
double underscore string so right
and it's called by the wrapper function
so if anybody has not noticed this
when you create
a double underscore method it is
associated
with a method
a built-in python method so you're
telling python
hey when this method gets used
come here and use it come in here and do
this
all right so now let's fix this right
now uh okay
so we commented that out so we need to
get
our double underscore wrapper
and did anybody notice what i did i left
out a double or i left out an underscore
all right and
so we stick with self
sorry my light seems brighter today so
you can see my cheery face
all right so this is the official
documentation
excuse me this is the official string
representation of the object
so basically what this is saying is when
you call this object back
is what did we do here
what is that do we have any idea what
that is
i don't and i don't think you do all
this is saying
is we got we got this
yeah we're going to be doing double
underscore main soon
that's a cool um run through so
it's that it's in this it's in that file
that you just ran the main file
it's this object and it's livid in this
memory other than that i i got i got no
idea i got nothing for you
here's here's here's the best that i can
do for you
but when we use wrapper double
underscore wrapper
we're going to tell python what to put
out on the screen
and i want
print
your rectangle
so when we used this up here it created
and came out to the screen and did this
but
let's do it
here is that where i have it
no that's not the one i want that as
our yes i want that as our string
this is wrapper
double underscore string so all right so
what i'm doing here
is we're going to just spit out this
let's just show it and then we'll go
through it
so before when i would press
when i would call our object a rectangle
object i would get this so now when i
call it i
get boom this right here
so i'm kicking out and i'm making this
nice neat and pretty and you can
use it now now let's look
and see our double underscore str
now that this is where it gets all right
str
called by string object with built-in
functions format
so it is the informal or printable
string representation of objects so if
by chance you did not
have a double underscore wrapper it
would come down here and pull
the string so let's do this because this
is where
this should go double underscore st
str double underscore self
and then does this return yeah this is
return
oh we got to put in memory
so when we call
so let's go over this real slow
so whatever when these are called as you
go through and
you all of the and we and we'll see this
in a second when we get to
iterators and generators all right
so the built-in functions that python
has
done all this tremendous work for us
when you want to interact when you have
an object
when you want to when you want to
interact with those
functions this is how you do it
all right i haven't clicked over and
looked at chat in a while
yes that is the memory ram address that
is exactly it
yes uh actually
that would be something that we can do
because i do want to get into
um is
and uh because copy
because you can get very lost into copy
very quickly so yes but that is the
memory address location
um how to deal with those but yes you're
correct you're absolutely correct
jan jan's got always got good questions
that is the ram address
on your system all right uh i digress
i can get i can get sucked in to this so
quickly but you guys
you guys are absolutely awesome and
absolutely awesome ask
awesome questions all right but this is
how you interact with python this is
where you begin
to control and have the
program user get what they need out of
it so when they
are using functions
this is how you control what comes out
to the screen
all right so we're 35 in
oh we have got to touch on inheritance
because that gets
very cool very quickly as well so
alright
so right here we just created a really
simple object
let me get
this hopefully i didn't drop this that
bad
so we created a little object
takes in two arguments
and then we know how to use
well create it then we know how to use
and interact with
the wrapper and the string
built in functions for python you
creating and using our
double underscore methods wrapper and
double underscore string
and then created two new methods
or two methods for our object
so where where python gets very very
powerful very quickly
it's called inheritance and what that is
is especially when you're wanting to
borrow
i'll give you a perfect example of
something and hopefully we're still
working together and we can
touch on it but you don't want to create
a new object
you just want to bring one in and either
shrink it or expand upon it
typically you'd expand upon it i don't
know why i said shrink it
but you go okay i like i like everything
about this
but there's a couple more things i'd
like to do
with it so you bring in this object
then you just add some so we're going to
sorry i think i have a delivery so
hopefully my dogs aren't going to go
to nuts for you all right
so we're going to deal with a
species dog and then
jump into breed
so we go class
[Music]
dog
species let's see if i spell this right
k9
so i'm gonna then we need to talk about
what i'm
there we go what i'm doing right now
voice and they bark
all right
so now what i'm doing here is i'm
hardwiring
so right now i haven't brought i don't
have anybody interacting
with any part of this i'm just creating
these attributes and i'm hardwiring them
in
so now when i call when i do
let's say uh
buster and he's a dog
boom buster
so there's my there's my object
and buster is
did i spell that right i didn't even
know yeah
sometimes okay so he's a canine
and then buster's voice
he barks now
this is where it gets cool alright so
so now if i bring in and i'm gonna
i want to do so what a breed of a dog
poodle
so i bring in dog
i'm going to inherit and
i don't know if we talked about pass
before keyword pass
basically it's telling python hey uh
i know i got some stuff here i have some
indention
just go ahead and ignore it for now and
i promise i'll fill it in later
sometime you don't have to but it'd be
odd if you had it there and didn't fill
it in
okay so um so now um
we have uh
rusty he's a poodle
oop did i not put that nope here
check this out so how did i make that
mistake
right here came up here so of course
poodle's not in memory right
because i didn't save it
rusty now i didn't pass anything
into all i did was come up here and say
go and grab
everything throw it into poodle
rusty then
his voice
he barks and then
[Music]
rusty dot you already see where this is
going
species he's a canine so all right
these are the building blocks and i want
to let this sit
and go from there but
and i'll just give you a little tease
so when you're building so it took me a
while to understand
what how how something can happen
so think about think about a character
in a video game
or even a block that's just sitting
there and
yeah how do we keep this sorry a bird
just flew into my window glad i didn't
yell
um so instead of doing functions so
th this is the beginnings of object
oriented
uh programming oop
you and i have we've been interacting
with functionality
functional programming lots of lots of
uh
lots of functions doing things this is
the building block where you set rules
and when an input happens to this object
or an event
you have all of these scenarios and
conditions
and then so like if you have
let's just go with the block so if it
gets hit with another
object you have rules for that and
methods that then go from there and
things happen
then if you get when you get more
complicated you have a character in a
game
you press the up button they do
something they'll move forward
and now with game sophisticated you're
going to need to then have the shoulders
move
maybe the head the torso and all of
these things
but instead of going through and having
to think of all these scenarios
you create an object then then that's
the player
then you create a player off that object
just like we do strings so just like
if i so i could do let's bring this back
this is a perfect
time to do this
so i have my x
let's keep this here then i have my y
and it's
you're getting the idea that's exactly
but
it wouldn't be quite as each each input
each input would have its own and then
you don't have to think about it
so as you're looping through like here's
a perfect example
with um with pygame
update so as you run the update you have
an update method for that object
so each time through if something's
happening if this condition is met
do this so then i have y and this is
going to be 2
by 6. so i have y
and x 2 separate rectangle
objects that are acting independently
from each other
it's all right all right my voice is
already fading so let's try to get
through we got i want to get through our
puzzle
i want to get through iterators and
generators
so all right i know this can get very
complicated very very quickly
let me get a cough drop i hope i haven't
been hacking too much for you guys
i know i love i love this stuff it's i
mean it's it's crazy to me
that it's still going down
to a processor either having power run
through it
or it's closed still still blows my mind
how sophisticated we've come from a
light lighting up or
not okay
there we go i could talk about this
forever
okay so we need to we need to talk about
iterables and iterators does anybody
have any idea the difference between the
two
so you iterate through
iterable objects so
iterators and iterables are like your
hand
all right all
all iterables
no i haven't said this in a while so i'm
going to mess this up
so you can iterate through iterables and
iterators
but not all iterables
are iterators let's look at it
so here is a perfect example
of me turning and iterable and we're
going to build upon it
and we're going to look at it so name
sam put this into memory
then we call dir
on name
which i want you to look
so we got our in it enter
oh okay
get an iterator from an object
callable iterable
so i can go through this
because they act the same but they are
not the same
and the main difference is the next
function
so i like to lead iterator into
generator all right
so an iterator uses
the next and double underscore
all right so right now i do not have a
double underscore
next so watch
so now for i am
whoa that's how many times i type that
then
print i
boom i get sam
i don't know why the birds are so active
today
all right so now now let's
wrap this up
it's an inner object so now let's run
dur on name
so we're going to get into it we're
going to get sophisticated really really
quickly after this and one of the things
that i love to do and i want to
i just don't want to jump into the time
module
i like to let this stuff sit and
percolate and then we go from there
so the basically the the main difference
oh wrong way
it's okay because you can iterate
over an aider and an iterable
all right because it has
next works so now now we need to look at
next this is how you go
through return the next item
from an iterator so where these become
very powerful
is let's say
when you have a command and you want to
go
through a iterable
but you don't want it to happen all at
one time
you just want to go through it
so let me put so now this is exhausted
so i need to turn this
off so i have i call name
name so there is my iterator
object then i call next on name
next on name
next on name and i call next on name one
more time
and it is exhausted so
all right so now that is our
that is our 4a this is our warm up to a
generator
so generator does and the reason why
generators are so very powerful
is they don't use up memory
so again when we do our time and i'm
going to show you
and they're fast they're ridiculously
fast so they're just sitting and
waiting to be used it's almost like they
have a set of instructions but they
haven't created anything
that's the best that i've uh come up to
explain it
they are a set of instructions and they
just go and do it when they need it
they haven't created anything they just
know what to do they go and touch it
come back
and just wait for the next one
kind of pun was intended i thought i'd
get well you guys just have to sit there
but i have a very captive audience i
have a very awesome audience you guys
are
um absolutely awesome
so yeah i think we can get to at least
75 minutes because we're going to do
generator
then i'm going to show you a little
puzzle that
i love to really get people to think
about
especially newer programmers of how to
set a rule
set up a rule of instructions because
you saw that with our
with our list here where we were
bouncing around and you had flow
all right i digress
sorry guys okay so a generator what in
the world is a generator
so basically a generator
is something that has a set of
instructions
that is sitting out there and waiting to
be done it's all right
uh seeing a jump up here so if you guys
are new here thanks for joining us today
i am sam from python basics this is our
uh
eighth ninth stream um and we are going
through
the absolute basics of python from the
beginning
heading towards intermediate and the
sky's
sky's the limit so um
all of these videos are uh
one are the pre all the previous
live streams are in a playlist
uh on free code camp and every single
topic that i have done here
are in micro videos on my channel in the
description down below
all right that's a little um admin right
there because i did see that it went
from about 200 to 250.
so i know i know sometimes i can get
all wound up and fly through some stuff
generators and very soon we will we will
show a awesome example i want wanna i
wanna
we haven't really messed with modules
that much
but uh time can be very tricky one
and so i just wanna introduce you guys
to generators and then we'll go from
there
so let's look at this and the difference
in the keyword so we know that return is
with a function
and literally how you go from a function
object to a generator
is is it where was it yeah iterator
object and this is how
you then are going to turn these into a
generator so n equals 0
then while in
less than num
yield
now how did i know i spelled that wrong
you guys could look at it and see
my word because it didn't go orange
then n plus equals one
boom then five equals
series i'm going to do this the short
way
we'll just do three so i'm creating a
well i could i should at least do that
since i'm calling it five
i realized that i complained about this
when i did it
so five okay generator object
series at this memory location
well jan you know what i really
appreciate that note jan is absolutely
correct
everything i'm a huge believer
in trying to be very thorough and also
building upon the next because look i
want you guys i
all right a little side note i remember
somebody told me
well just you just need to be more
confident go go get some confidence
what does that mean how do you just go
get some confidence all right
i want you to do these little skills
these little building blocks
i want you to know how to do it i want
you to have success
success and confidence are they're the
same
so i want you to be able to build these
things these little little things
have success building these things
get confident building these things and
then become more confident
one of the coolest things that i get to
do
is read the comments of of these huge
programs these lines of code that people
write because of the things that i
showed them
that's probably the coolest thing that's
part of all this so jan that is a great
shout out
if you're seeing this for the first time
if you're seeing me for the first time
thanks for being here
do not be intimidated just a side note
to remind everybody
i started learning to program when i was
36 years old
i'm dyslexic can't type can't spell um
i have add if i can do it anybody can do
it okay
that's just type
code follow along
go back rewatch them do it again all
right
awesome shout out jan thank you so much
okay
so now let's run dur on five
boom so then i do next
on five i get
zero i go next on five i go one
that's done five two next time five
three so where should this exhaust
boom one
two three four five now we could have
started it
one and gone through but i have i have
five objects in and we're gonna we're
gonna expand upon this
and we're gonna go from we're gonna go
from here but this is our
introduction to objects
generators iterables so now
all right so we're at 56 we're gonna do
a cool little puzzle
to get us to think of patterns
i love i love going back to this so if
you guys haven't seen this
oh is that i got to draw my little sad
little stick figure
i think so so a guy a robot
whatever standing here he's got a bobble
head
so he's got to walk and go through here
so how can he touch
all nine circles with a repeatable
pattern
and this was one of the first ones that
i saw
and that i don't that i liked in my kids
class of how that they had to solve this
everything else was
open for interpretation but i thought it
was great for loops
so here's a set of instructions to touch
all of these and then you can put
that one set of instructions into a loop
of three
so go forward go all the way down turn
180 degrees
come all the way up turn to the right
boom completely repeatable
so step forward turn to the right go
forward
two turn 180 degrees go forward two
turn to the right you're literally in
this position
right here so that loop you can repeat
then two more times so literally those
set of instructions you would do
three times and i want you to think
about it we did that
with our loop right here we're coming
through
we're setting down and then we've solved
this problem down here
where we loop back through and turn that
into a plus
so here is the puzzle that we're going
to do right now
and it's i i think it's a great example
and especially
to get us to think of how to solve this
and be very concise and we're going to
we're going to be exposed to a new
a new keyword
so the puzzle is round to the nearest
5 if so it's a grading scale it's a
it's a math puzzle for programming
and the teacher wants to have
wants to round up two so if
if a kid gets
the student gets a
78 it'll round up
to a 80.
they get a 77
it stays a 77.
so if it is within
so if it's if it is within
2 of the next 10 so if it is a
then a 90 so would that be a 93
93 it rounds
up to a 95.
now we could do this longhand and have
every single
one of these scenarios but
that's not pythonic that's not
programming that's not concise
that's cheating so this is a great
mental exercise
and recognition of a pattern that's what
this is
this is a recognition of a recognition
of a pattern
forward turn right
turn 180 degrees one way or the other go
forward two more
turn to the right again repeatable
consistent
concise one set of four five
sets of instructions repeated three
times
so here's here's our dilemma
so this is what i want you guys to think
about so if it was a 72
it would stay a 72 because it is not
within
it is not within
2 of the next 95 now if it was a 74
which these would be these would be my
grades when i was in school
74 would be rounded up to a 75.
all right so let's get into it so first
we're going to take in
so we need to figure out how we're going
to do this
and we're just going to take the
function so let's just let's just take
in a function
or we're going to call it fives
now we need to we need to think of it
think about this
how can we then
get
what information do we care about we
care
how close where it is what it is
how close to the to the five right so we
need to start examining
let's bring this down
all right i think that's good am i still
within frame all right
okay good let's bring that up a little
bit
yeah okay pass
so we're going to start so if i want to
so if i'm if i only care about
a number if it's close to five well wait
a second
if it's close to five i'm going by units
of five
so what tool do i have to keep up with
counting by fives this is a perfect
example
how do we how do we find out if
something was an even or an odd number
jan do you remember how we did that with
even or odd
because basically we're counting by twos
so now we're going to be counting by
fives
no i never tested to see how delayed the
module
the uh oops i almost said it modulos
bingo
so 74 divided uh modulo
4. excuse me modulo 5
get a remainder of 4.
so let's do this a little longhand i'm a
huge fan of longhand until we begin to
see
what a pattern is so
74 would be rounded up to 75.
72 modulo 5 would
oops whoa 72
modulo 5 is a remainder of
2. so that wouldn't get rounded up
but 73 modulo
5 would get rounded up
so let's look on the other side so let's
do so 80
88 would be rounded up to 100 right
90 98 or excuse me 98.99 would both be
rounded up to
100.
so wouldn't get rounded up
would get rounded up
would get rounded up would get rounded
up
would not get rounded up anybody
anybody noticing the pattern yet
so when when would
anybody see it yet
so basically
if my remainders are
three and four
i will round up to the next
five so we're going to do this
a very long way
and then i'm going to show you a very
cool
concise so we got if x
modulo 5
equals x
plus equals 1.
so
that is that is absolutely very very
true
uh you can just you can just put your
head down and whatever
the assignment whatever the workload is
so all right
so if it's five we know we're gonna have
a remainder if the remainder is four
we know we're going to need to add one
because what we're rounding to the next
five so let's look at this really close
and then
l if
x modulo 5
3 x
plus equals 2.
so how did i come up with two
two and three equals five
rounding up to the next five
so if i come here
and i test so if i have a list
grades
uh what 72 98
94 83
71 73
and uh
100. let's see if i did this right
for grade in grades
5's grade
so 72
actually let's get fancy
i haven't done that in a while does that
work
you have to forgive me i haven't tested
any of that there we go
there we go so shouldn't have rounded
rounded
rounded rounded
shouldn't have rounded rounded and
shouldn't around it
so there we go now
bingo they add up to five so
let's get let's get fancier
let's get a little bit more
let's get a little bit more logic based
so we're still kind of manually
manipulating this because we're still
going through and doing math
but what is what is a more
concise
realization of this pattern
and we're going to learn who's used or
keyword or i'm just thinking about that
we need to do one for and
and it's eluding me right now okay i
know i mean i know i have one
but uh who's seen the or keyword anybody
jan
okay all right this is where it gets
really really concise very very quickly
so i can put this all on three line i
put all this on three lines
but it's just thinking through the
problem thinking through the pattern
5 equals
3 or
so this being true
or this being true so we're going to
look at this
um 1
equals 1 or 1
equals 2. true
so 1 equals 2
or 1 equals
3. false
so
right it only has to have one true
and has to have both or all oh yeah we
need to do all
we need to do and any and all i need to
make a note of that
hang on let me do that now
for two weeks from now uh
and all any
and time we'll do time all right
so dude where are we where are we all
right
we're boiling we're boiling this down uh
or x modulo 5
equals right so it's
this scenario or this scenario
now here's where the math gets really
fun and this is
this is the math that i love i love to
do
all right
no no no look you guys are doing
phenomenal i forget who was saying that
they had already done a bot
i don't care about jargon i don't care
if you use the right
jargon or or not i mean if you have the
underlying concept
uh yeah that's that's exactly it
having the jargon and typing exactly
right
that's practice understanding how to lay
these out
that's the important part you can go and
google
wow what where where to use it but if
you don't know what to use it's
pointless
that you don't have to remember any of
this there have been so many times
i've gone back that's why you never
delete anything don't
ever delete anything just comment it out
or make or shove it over and and com
yeah comment that out do a new one
just go back and it's for a variety of
reasons one it's a resource that you
have that you've already done and a
problem you've already solved that you
can go back and look at
two it's to then also see the
development that you've done
sorry let's do this and start wrapping
it up because
my voice is my voice is uh fading fast
i like that yes reed have the
if you guys don't know the zen of python
make sure you
make sure you look at it let's do this
jan you remember how to bring it in
boom zen of python
it's literally that import this
yep bam bingo all right
so now let's clean this up make this
very concise
just like our picture well not my
picture but the concept
forward turn right go forward two more
180
right or left forward two turn right
boom you're done repeat those
instructions three times
all right uh let's see bring this down
so now what pattern have we noticed
with this so check this out
x plus equals
5
minus x modulo
5.
so if it's off by 4 we add one
if it's off by three we add two
so as long we just want these to equal
five
right so that's why this modulo
if it equals three we subtract that 3
from 5.
we get 2 we add 2 to x
if this is equal to 4 5 minus this
would be one we only add one
print x
it's a boom and
helps if you use the correct
boom same same output
exact same output not move
should move should move should move not
move
should move not move so boom
so there we go this is probably one of
my
favorite one of my favorite puzzles
uh well i got a i got a couple
i love the chicken nugget one from um uh
the mit puzzle
have we done that yet jan have we done
the
finding finding chicken nugget
combinations yet
i know we did nth prime number and then
we did
what was our decorator we did a nested
function
for uh i can't remember what it was
but this is one of my favorites the um
chicken nugget count is one
if we haven't done that i'll go back and
look at the notes i guess well i guess
i'd
look right here
uh
chicken no we haven't and then also
second conversion
so we're gonna do all these so i'll
sprinkle in these puzzles
in between uh in between the concept
for um for our
for our python so i appreciate everybody
and to remind everybody
uh we will be off next week we will
rejoin
in two weeks um be a great time to go
back and catch up
watch the previous live streams beau has
done an awesome job they are sitting
in their own little playlist you can go
back and watch
uh all of them any of them and any
concept that
you can't remember where what stream it
was in you can jump back over
and i really like to
i gotcha um
uh oh any of these concepts that
uh or items in here
i have a i have a single specific video
for every single topic that we've ever
done here so if you can't remember what
live stream it was
jump over to my channel do a search for
it it'll jump right up
but i just want to tell you guys thank
you i greatly appreciate
all your attention all your questions
and all your awesome support
and i will see you guys in two weeks
and always thanks again guys and we'll
see you guys next time
bye